so uh take a breath what have we done so
far
we have for this particular complex
number z which satisfies this equation
since it satisfies that equation um it
has to sit somewhere on this
circumference
we have gone and created the diagram and
then we've used that
to find the maximum values of the
modulus of z so i've got them down
here okay what does the last part of
this question ask us
confirm your answer the one we just
found that inequality
to the previous part by using the
triangle inequality this guy here and
then they
provide the expression for you so before
we go any further you can see that the
whole idea here is
we had to use a lot of geometric
reasoning and thinking we had to create
a whole diagram and think about the
modulus and what it meant we had to do
all that geometric reasoning
to solve in this particular way the one
we've just completed
but this triangle inequality which you
can see is just written in algebra here
it's kind of like
an algebraic summary of a whole bunch of
other geometric reasoning that's where
you can see that the name is the
triangle inequality it comes from the
relationships
between the sides of a triangle any
triangle and the fact that certain sides
when you add them together
can't exceed um the the longer side and
all the right sort of thing so all that
geometric reasoning is is part of the
dna if you like
of this triangle inequality but once
it's been baked in
we can kind of just use it um it's a
little bit like the pythagorean identity
in trigonometry
cos squared plus sine squared
equals one this comes from a right
angled triangle particularly a right
angle triangle in the unit circle whose
x coordinate is cos its y coordinate is
sine and the radius of that circle is
one
so this comes from geometric reasoning
but once you establish that
um you know you don't have to do any
diagrams or geometric reasoning to use
this in a trigonometric identity proof
you can just say
anytime i see cos square plus sine
squared i can just say that's one i can
substitute it right
so that's exactly what we're trying to
do here we're trying to use the
geometric reasoning that's inherent
within this
to solve this question find the maximum
minimum values
of the modulus of z without having to
appeal to any geometry at least not
you know drawing at our cells so what
we're going to do is we're going to
write out the triangle inequality and
see how we can use it
to confirm this result that's the one
which we've already worked out but we
want to try and uh prove that it's the
case
all right so here comes the triangle
inequality i'll just write it out
it's uh absolute value absolute value of
z take away as the value w
absolute value again take a breath then
you've got
less than or equal to and you go up
there to make sure you're writing
everything correctly
it's going to be the absolute value of z
plus w
which is less than or equal to again the
absolute value of z
are the modulus of z plus the modulus of
w
separately and you just have a look back
you're like did i get it all right looks
okay to me all right so this is part d
so what i'm seeking to do is i want to
prove this result i want to prove this
result
using this okay now in the same way that
when you had a look earlier on i was
trying to understand
uh what does this mean
in the context of this equation that got
provided to us and so i had to choose
an appropriate value of w that if i i
put it into here
would give me the result up here right
now i still have this
as the same foundation for my question
right so i've got let's write it down
here
the absolute value of z minus 2 minus i
it
equals 1. i'm somehow going to have to
use it
but i want to choose a value of w
that if i put it in here will give me
something related to each of these guys
now look at them carefully which of
these one
two three which section of the
inequality
is going to be most easy to use to
transform it
into looking like something like this
well we can do this
through a process of fairly simple
elimination if it's not immediately
apparent to you which one is the most
useful let's have a look at the right
hand side for example
this is the module of z modulus of z
plus the modulus of w
there's two separate moduli here right
and because they're two separate ones
you can see
you know in here i've only got one right
this is the absolute value of z
take away some other stuff and there
isn't another absolute value sign or
module sign that appears
and you have the same problem when you
have a look at the left-hand part of the
inequality you've got
you don't just have two absolute values
you've got a third one
bracketing the whole thing so neither
this part of the inequality nor
this part of the inequality neither of
them will be very good to use to
transform it into this
the only candidate left is this guy in
the middle so i need to choose an
appropriate value of w
that if i put it into here
will land with this now maybe you can
think about it it's not exactly the same
as what we started with
up here because i'm substituting into z
minus w
here but i'm trying to substitute into z
plus w here
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say let
w equal minus 2
minus i let's see what happens when we
substitute this in
i can say if i take this and put it into
the triangle
inequality let's give me myself another
line here
what am i going to get well i'll just do
the substitution without even really
thinking about it first and see what i
end up with okay
so first absolute value of modulus for z
take away now here's the first time i'm
going to substitute in w so it goes
minus 2 minus i close my modulus
and my absolute value less than or equal
to
that's the first part let's do the next
part modulus of
z plus and then here's the second
substitution so it's minus 2
minus i and then close my modulus
last one modulus of z
plus modulus of minus 2 minus
i there we go so just to highlight i
have chosen
this guy here and i've substituted into
the triangle inequality in
let's count them up one two
three spots okay now that i've put it in
let's see if we end up with something
useful what have i got over here on the
left hand side well
absolute value of modulus of z take away
now
what is this point minus 2 minus i well
i already know what the modulus of this
point is
because it's the opposite of this point
over here it's just
see how this is 2 plus i minus 2 minus i
is just going to be on the opposite side
of the origin
somewhere here i guess so being that
it's the same distance it's just in the
other direction
it's going to have the same modulus this
is going to be root 5 again so i'm just
going to write that in
root 5 less than or equal to okay what
happens in the middle here well i can
expand my brackets
and i get z minus 2 minus i
and before i go and write the rest of
the triangle inequality this is a big
relief
because this thing here is something i
can use
from the basis of the question this
thing is equal to one so on the next
line i'll be able to do
a substitution i'm not there yet i've
finished my inequality
i should write less than or equal to and
then finally i've got the absolute value
of z
plus and i worked out this modulus
earlier the modulus of w
is just root five okay
so i'm almost there you can see if i
just highlight this i
used orange before so this guy here
comes from the original question right
for my particular value of z this thing
is always going to be equal to one i can
just do that substitution
right so in fact what i'm going to do
i'll be a teeny bit lazy here
everything else on the outsides of this
inequality stays put
but this guy in here oops i only did the
top
i can substitute that with one and you
can see that just comes from
uh the question right so this is my
substitution here
i'll do it like that hopefully you can
see that clearly enough
and so now um i have to think about how
will i get from this line here
this weird awkward uh mess with
all these absolute values and like
multiple parts of this triangle
inequality
and remember what am i trying to prove
i'm trying to prove this line up here
this is
i did it geometrically before but now
i'm just trying to use the triangle
inequality now when you have a look at
this look at it closely
i know there's a very natural instinct
to do
something like this take this right hand
side
look at that it's so tempting to use
these two parts
of the triangle inequality because all
the pieces that i want
are there right you're like oh look i'm
looking for a modulus of z
by itself and that's there i'm looking
for a 1
which is there and i'm looking for a
root 5 which is there it looks
so tantalizingly close so let's see what
happens if i just use this let's just
oops it doesn't let's just follow the
line of logic
because you're going to see something
perhaps that you didn't
expect that hopefully will make sense
once i explain it i'm just going to
write 1 is less than or equal to modulus
of z
plus root 5. so i've taken the the right
hand part of the inequality and i've
just written it separately
to the other part of the triangle
inequality i want to make uh you know
the modulus for zed the subject right
you can see it's there in the middle
there of the result i'm trying to prove
so
what do i do here i'm going to have to
subtract root 5
from both sides so let's go ahead and
write that 1 minus root 5
less than or equal to modulus of z um i
want to make modulus of
the the subject of this so i'm going to
switch the direction of this inequality
i'll swap sides so
if the modulus is over here now the
direction of the
inequality has switched and i've still
got 1 minus root 5
over here now
this statement is true it's just not
very helpful because have a look at what
it says
really carefully right it says the
modulus of z now what is the modulus of
z it's a magnitude right it's a it's a
length it's a distance um the the
smallest it can be is
zero if z were on the origin right so
i'm saying that this distance is greater
than or equal to this guy
but hold on a second like it's one take
away
root five root five is about 1.7
something or other
so one take away that is is a negative
number so you're like
the modulus for z is greater than or
equal to a negative number well i
already knew that i already knew that it
was going to be greater than or equal to
0.
so while this is true it gives us
nothing useful
for solving the question so instead i
kind of have to grip my teeth
and look over at this other part of the
triangle
inequality now i was resisting doing it
because it looks like a gobbled mess and
i'm like oh my gosh there's like
um absolute values inside absolute
values i was trying my best to avoid it
but you can't because as you can see
looking at the other side is not useful
so in the same way let's just write this
part of the triangle inequality by
itself and then
see if we can interpret it so it's the
absolute value of
modulus of z take away root 5 absolute
value
less than or equal to 1.
does this thing mean now the for me when
i first
encountered questions like this um what
weirds my brain now is the absolute
values of absolute values it's really
hard to
lose like keep track of what on earth
does this even mean what does it look
like
so what i'm going to encourage you to do
even though we went via this technique
to try to avoid some geometry i'm going
to
bring back a visual approach to try and
think about this right
if i asked you just uh you know take
this as a side piece of logic right
if i ask you to consider uh the absolute
value of x
is less than or equal to one this is the
other challenge right it's not just the
absolute values in absolute values it
also combined with these inequalities
what would this mean now i think most
people would be happy to solve this but
looking at it visually rather than
algebraically i think is very
instructive
if i think about what this means this
guy here it's the function as the value
of x
when is that function beneath or equal
to
1. so if i were to draw i really i don't
know why i drew that so small
if i were to draw a quick and dirty
sketch of the absolute value of
x it might look something like this
this v shape graph here i'm looking for
where is this graph
beneath the line y equals 1 so if i put
in here i'll do a dotted so you can see
it a little more clearly
here comes y equals 1. i'm looking for
the section underneath this which i hope
you can all see is going to be this
section
under here wow that was bigger than i
expected it to be
this section in here so i'm looking for
now the x values
that will result in that and you can
clearly see this is going to be negative
1
this is going to be 1. so what i really
mean by
the absolute value of x is less than or
equal to 1 i can state that
same inequality without absolute values
it's between
1 uh sorry negative 1
and 1. that's that's my boundaries right
so how does that relate
to this complex numbers question up here
well i can continue my logic
and i can say well what that really
means is this two-sided inequality
like the triangle inequality that this
guy in here
this here i might as well just grab it
this thing in here
the thing that's inside the absolute
values has to be between negative one
and one like so so you can see the
parallel between this line
and this line here and you when you see
this written you're like oh
okay like algebraically there's not much
to go here but you really need to
understand how you got from this line
to this line or rather from this line to
this line you're thinking
visually to say that this absolute value
is less than or equal to one
means you're between negative one and
one and then you can solve accordingly
so now i'm so close right i'm just going
to take all three sections of this and
i'm going to add root 5
to everything so i get root 5 minus 1
less than or equal to modulus of z less
than or equal to
what i was doing i was adding root 5 to
everything and you can see
that this is indeed what we got in the
earlier part here
but we didn't have to draw this new
argon diagram to sort of
and reason through this circle and all
that kind of thing we
sort of used the triangle inequality it
bakes the geometry
in and so that's how we can prove this
result so be really careful
with your inequalities they take a lot
of careful thought and you don't want to
just
apply processes mindlessly you want to
consider what the things mean and then
how you can choose the appropriate path
through them because some of them as you
can see
end up with dead ends